foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
hey guys let's get right to it I'm not
feeling good I'm not feeling good I'll
be honest I had to pause there you know
I was trying to put on this show that
I'm I'm happy and Dolly but in all
honesty I'm I'm I'm I'm hurting Ryan and
both yeah yeah dude there's listen it's
okay I I'm the king of just being like
it sucks it sucks right now like there's
no reason to pretend like you're happy
sometimes you just wake up and you're
like yeah today sucks I haven't even
started today yet that was one of those
days can't sugarcoat it at all we've
been pretty poor but it is a new day
it's a new week I'm not gonna get too
high I'm not gonna get too low I've been
too low already
might as well just get on with it let's
go we've been poor my team's been poor
uh it's it's just you know
it's just not going the way that we I
wanted to go but that is okay because
you know what they like to say you can
always bet again another day Ryan what
was that that you were what is that go
ahead well we just gonna ignore that I
gave out an exact series order
play last last weekend we're only two
legs away
Celtics win two straight games and it's
over you know what it you know what it
is Greg I just realized if we if we just
shower producer Ryan with praise maybe
that's the way we win I mean he's been
hot he's been hot I mean just give him
his credit today I'm not gonna say the
magic words but he's been hot
magic words no magic words don't worry
about it
producer Ryan has
a fading you know he has been hot uh
but you know what that means that means
drop your best bet for tonight's game in
the chat because producer Ryan thinks
that he's the guy he thinks that I know
everybody
honestly I could see it in your face
in all honesty I'm really willing to let
Ryan take the show and just uh drive the
bus today
the bus I mean he's hot he's hot
so you're basically saying like it's
like what Chuck says every now and again
about about Kevin Durant and some of
these guys is that I need to be the bus
driver today right like I can't be
you're hot yeah I can't be a bus rider I
gotta be a bus driver no absolutely no
okay you got to be a bus driver uh but
let me welcome everybody to the show if
everybody woke up to the show if you
don't know I'm about to tell you my name
is Greg Ivory next to me to your right
you looking right it's a man I like to
call MB Michael Bolin he is the man of
the app until you're left uh
is the man
we like to call producer Ryan he's hot
right now so all respect to producer
Ryan he is hot he is on the bus driver
and he's gonna drive the bus today he's
going to drive the bus today but like I
said make sure you guys drop all your
bets in the chat once again we are
talking 76ers Celtics Sons nuggets Ryan
what are the people talking about in the
chat uh the people are giving plays like
it's nobody's business it's hard to keep
up uh first thing I see is from uh Coop
Diggity Dog
sometimes the username's cats me uh hoop
diggity dog too says uh Devin Booker
over 32 and a half that that's gonna be
a fat no for me I'm already on his I'm
already on his unders that's gonna be
it's gonna be a no uh El Bay KD 30 plus
and two threes what's up elbe welcome
back uh B Thompson is a fellow nuggets
fan tonight's a Jamal night
interesting
interesting very interesting I have some
interest in Jamal Murray he plays so
much better at home man it's crazy how
much better he is of a player at home I
don't know what it is but I think he
might be right I kind of like that
especially coming off like jokic coming
off like a 50 point game like I think
Burger yeah I think getting Jamal around
here at like 25 and a half is I don't
want to call it stealing or theft or
robbery
but it feels well we just got to figure
out now you're the bus driver so you got
to tell us whether we're going you see
what Brian's trying to do you got to
tell us whether we're going big odds or
we're going safe it's up to you man bro
it's up to you you are driving the bus
today you're the you're the guy that's
hot
yeah man all right this is there's a lot
of freshmen Greg this this is this is
pressure for him but it's like we're
gonna sit here and this parlay is gonna
be plus 1200 or something yeah it is
we'll have to see what's up
I'm with it let's
go
right down yeah let's over the fire uh
I
so B Thompson says Jamal
um
I what if we bumped it down it says is
Jamal yeah what so I don't know if he
met over 25 and a half I'm gonna assume
you can't just jump in here and be like
I like Jamal tonight but I only like
Jamal for 18 when his line is 25 and a
half so I am okay if we go a smidge
under it
and say take
22 and a half at minus 245. I think you
can get I think if Jamal didn't get 23
tonight that would be
a criminal I think it would be cause for
dismissal from Denver
um so I think I think that's I think
that's a good place to start if you guys
are okay with it you gotta think man
yeah jokic ain't gonna score 50 points
again you you assume
and they he scored 50 points and they
lost if he doesn't score 23 24 points
they might be going back to Phoenix down
3-2 exactly another another thing
another thing guys Jamal's going back
home
yep you know what I'm saying he he's
going to play different at home than he
does on the road
I see something interesting in the chat
blaze1321 says doc says his starters
will play a lot of minutes tonight
gotta assume that's like a general game
plan but if that's like a report
I don't know what Jason Tatum's been
doing and I see some plays in here
Tatum 30 is a lock KB 225 I can't I
don't know if I can do that what do you
think Ryan no I
here's the thing I do think that Jason
Tatum like
I think that Jason Tatum will actually
go off tonight I so I will say that
but my other thing is is like how many
times on this show
have have we said you know I agree Ryan
yeah and like I could believe it but
that also doesn't mean that I have to
bet on like the amount of times that I
sit down and I say like I think that
this is gonna happen but I don't bet on
it it's just like a that's an everyday
occurrence for me so like I agree with
you but that's gonna be a no
yeah I'm gonna agree as well I mean how
many times we're gonna let this guy
smoke us like if he has a good game
great you know whatever but yeah hey uh
I'm in the comments guys and I see
something that really catches my
attention really because that's it
Raymond Fuentes says Malcolm Brogden
points rebounds and assist
Ryan I mean you know we are letting you
drive the bus right and we're just
bringing you know I got the keys in the
ignition you got the keys to the
ignition uh do you like Malcolm
brogden's pra do you think he's going to
be uh do you think he's gonna have to
play well in order for the Celtics to
get a win today so my only thing with
that is we can't
if we're going to use Malcolm brogden's
pra we can't add anything else from this
game uh because we can't same game
parlay it but
um
we banked on him last week to score 10.
that was easy cheese man I think he had
23 points yeah so yeah if we can't go
pra does Malcolm Brogden does anything
stand out to you
nah people are gonna call me crazy but I
actually like the other backup guard to
have a better better game today Derek
white I think Derek white has been
struggling these past few games
um he kind of found his stroke a little
bit at uh I think it was in game three
um or it might have been game two but
um I I like I like Derek white tonight a
lot better than Brogden and again like
yeah if we could same game parlay
brogden's you know points assist pra
whatever then sure but we can't and I
his line being 15 and a half like I
don't know about you guys but that seems
like a lot for a guy who's not gonna
start the game on the court it's trappy
man and I think they're just following
what the public is doing the public is
probably hammering Brogdon because of
how he played last game or the last
couple games
so that's tough I don't know I don't
want to fall into a trap I just want to
win man but it's Ryan's show he's got
the bus on the but the bus is going 65
on the highway so just gotta keep
rolling
uh okay well
go ahead
I mean
never mind just just go right because
you guys are talking about Malcolm
Brockman and you're gonna know why I
feel this way later in the show but uh
respect on my man Malcolm Brogden you
know
I am I'm just saying it's a lot of
points can I interest you in this
Malcolm Brogdon in his last five games
against the Sixers has hit five three
six two and two threes
that's all above that one and a half
number
these numbers and he's playing at home I
think it's one and a half for threes
right yes and before I move by the way I
just would like to say as I was talking
up Derek white his number went from 11
and a half to 12 and a half I'm not
gonna say anything else about that you
draw your own
never mind
that's a good leg
do you like that Greg I mean if you're
if you're gonna quietly not you're not
talking about Malcolm Brogden but you're
you're foreshadowing I love that I love
that to go get two threes I love that
and whatever I mean let's just look I
mean I I think bowling already said this
but he had two three two main three six
main threes three made threes and five
made threes average and four made threes
on the series I'll take Malcolm Brogden
to go yes sir two
two that's it at home
I know
home rims you telling me you gotta eat
at the crib and all he got to get is two
I'll tell him
yeah yeah
I I agree I agree this does yeah
um
do you really agree Ryan because I I
don't know bro because I'm also I looked
up and I see Derek whites also at one
and a half and I'm like do we need to
take them both no but we can't they're
both backup guards for the Celtics like
it's just it's not a recipe for Success
we can't be taking two overs for two
guys on the bench it's a bat it's a bad
Omen I don't like it because then we're
gonna get angry with brogden's in the
game and White's sitting and then they
swap and we need them both to be there
at the same time it's just not good it's
not it's not good I got you you know
what you know what and I I yeah I got
you we got two from this game you know
who's gonna get Buckets today
who's that
who those boys from the Suns both of
them both of them no bro stop all right
don't worry stop it you'd already know
about Devin Booker's under no I know but
there's another guy over there there's
another guy over there he said both boys
from the Suns
of course one of them's Booker but if
you're fading Booker there's another
there's another guy over there that's
getting buckets Ryan
but I'm sorry I'm so sorry this is
definitely getting you're driving he's
trying to steer you I'm just trying to
steer you in a way your your backseat
driving your backseat driving that's
what you're doing I mean
are we in a boat now you said he's
driving the boat so he took the bus to
the marina
I hope the boat drops us off at the
airport next
next
the last five games for KD in points
against the Nuggets 36-39 24 29 29.
legitimately who can guard him on that
team who can go a different book I mean
no sir no song
Devin Booker I mean you're gonna cover
it later Brian but I love the idea of
playing KD here because
yeah Booker is definitely due for a
little bit of regression it's still
going to be probably shooting 55 from
the field and scoring 30 points yeah if
he regresses enough
I see KD having at least 30
and we can get a play in this parlay a
lot cheaper than that so let's check out
KD for that late game for sure
all right so we we like him at 30 plus
30.
it's KD baby it's 30 plus minus 180 oh
my God that's crazy I know
yeah that's crazy I mean I I do think
that he's gonna get 30 but to lay that
type of juice on on Katie to make 30
points concrete
well it just depends on how we want this
to go right Ryan and now we're on the
boat so which way is the boat going are
we going for Value town or are we going
to to try and get to the window it's up
to you man I'm excited right I like the
way you I like the way you rephrase that
because it is it's up to you it's up to
you right which way you try to steer
this this [__] this is this is crazy
Greg every week he's trying to fill his
agenda and we give him the keys to the
bus he drives us to the marina
he's cotton playing over there
I'll be honest with you I'm still
because my head's still on like two do I
like do I like the products and threes
or not and we're talking about we're
talking about Kevin's rent and I'm still
thinking about Malcolm Brogden no the
the Brogden leg is money that's a lot he
has a letter everybody went through his
numbers all right bro okay all right uh
um
is
right driving a rusty Winnebago
[Laughter]
bro okay Starvin Martian says play it
safe we're trying to win
so let's do 25.
that doesn't okay yeah borderline does
absolutely nothing for us but that's
okay all right okay so that's a lockity
lock block
okay for sure they need to get 25 is a
lot
all right so then we need to figure out
what to do with this fourth leg and I
kind of want it to be
juicy so I need somebody to beat
Thompson let's talk about my guy jokic
I I don't want to do anything with jokic
tonight
do we
do you agree or no I I think jokic
probably gets
close to a triple double tonight he
didn't rebound as well as everyone
wanted him to in the last game I think
that probably changes I think the sun's
probably missed more shots than they
made at home so his rebounds probably
the only thing that I would really lean
in on and like I said I think Murray I
agreed with our our chat Murray's gonna
have a good game tonight I would think
so
if it's not rebounds I'm definitely
leaving you official on tonight like he
might have a 16 rebound game with like
12 points and eight assists which is a
good game yeah but I don't expect him to
score I think
no I like that Envy because I think like
you know he he didn't rebound good last
game and they lost so what is he gonna
try what do they all do you know after
games they all make adjustments to try
to get better and so I think like in
this game he's going to try to put an
emphasis on grabbing rebounds so I I
like the way you're thinking right there
indeed
B Thompson says jokic assists El Bay
says eight assists I'm not sure where
that number is at value-wise but
I could definitely see him dishing more
than he's scoring I mean that's a huge
load 52 points is unbelievable and in a
loss they have to adjust like you said
Greg because obviously him being the
focal point and even scoring almost half
their points didn't even work hey Ryan
they're gonna have to get back to base
that 10 assists is plus money I know you
say you wanted to make this one a little
juicy I know I
well because here's here's my deal
here's what I we can't parlay this so
this is I I'm I'm trying not to blow our
spot here but let's go down to
oh no it's minus 18. I was gonna say we
just had this and then we'll add three
likes of the other game but that's
impossible
um okay
I do want to give uh some shine to our
guy talking edits here who I missed
before when we were talking about Kevin
Durant but I think we could probably
settle I mean
I don't hate the idea of him getting 10
assists I I actually do think I would
probably I'd be willing to take this
straight up
yeah I would too I mean like like Greg
look what that did to those odds boy I
like it I like it because Greg you made
a great point my bro
he's gonna have to do something
different I mean he's still going to be
aggressive I see Savvy six says still
gonna be aggressive because they can't
guard him obviously we know that but
even him being aggressive like they're
gonna have to make shots Caldwell Pope
Michael Porter Bruce Brown those guys
are gonna have to make shots they're not
gonna win the recipe is there they lost
the game where he scored 52 points they
got to switch it up
gotta gotta make adjustments that's what
the playoffs are all about
how can we match up on that clipboard
how can we make adjustments in
I think Ah that's how I all right Ryan I
got a proposition for you brother go
ahead you ready yeah we have a
four-legged parlay of 422 right now
Greg do we toss do we toss in Orion leg
just so we can uh have a little extra
steak on this thing tonight just let
Ryan pick the final leg of the far leg I
don't know
he did pick the whole parlay there's not
a single one of them I dude this is from
the chat it says Chad's poorly on the
screen
yeah of course it says Chad's parlay but
before we set you're driving the bus and
then you started driving the boat and
now we're on our way to the jetway
because you're about to drive the
airplane and take this home home and go
straight to the Moon we're about to get
on a rocket ship if that's if this is
the plan we're about to go on a rocket
ship Greg
well let's go bro take us there I mean
Ryan are you down at another layer I'm
down if you're in uh I'm I'm down just
one second here because talking edits
was talking about KD rebounds while we
were talking about KD points and I do
think 25 plus is a lock but
he he's been pretty much leading the
Suns in rebounds throughout this series
his line is at eight and a half I think
we could probably get him at
six we can get him at six for a better
number than we got him at 25 plus points
I like it I'm looking at the numbers
right now and the last five against the
Nuggets he's had 11 9 8 14 and 7. that's
all clearing that number yeah lock it in
okay
so that's what we're gonna do we're
gonna do this surprise so far right so
so far we have Jamal Murray over 22 and
a half points jokic over nine and a half
assists Kevin Durant six plus rebounds
and Malcolm Brogden over one and a half
threes I also just very quickly because
we're gonna add a fifth leg so we we're
we can afford doing let's go eight
assists oh I was gonna say Murray 20
plus points because all of a sudden do
both of them could do both of them let's
see if you're gonna add a fifth leg do
both of them
Murray and then eight assists I don't
yeah that's a good plan
it's a good because at the end of the
day man like we could we could salivate
all we want over the value yeah which is
kind of freaking win man we do have to
win we've got to see one go in yes sir
so the only thing that's kind of going
okay did I you know I know it just got
taken off the screen but it said Ryan's
parlay and this is a team this is this
is a team building exercise oh no oh no
Ryan
this is all evil you know it's funny too
is that yeah see and it just happened it
just happened I was gonna say we're
gonna be snarky put Ryan's parlay but
now I got in my ear can you read the
parlay so I know what we're doing this
is unbelievable you know you see you
need me you need me
Kevin Durant six plus rebounds Jamal
married 20 plus points yokich a plus
assists and Malcolm Brockton over one
and a half threes they're so bad they're
so upset they're they're very upset
um all right but the last leg the last
leg fifth leg
this just also happens to be we'll just
a transition into Best Bets
um and I'll start off and then you guys
can go but this will be the last leg
this is this is great
okay
Jalen Brown
has been a menace
in the first quarter has just been on
fire
um every game this series except for one
he has scored eight or more points last
series however against the Atlanta Hawks
he only did that twice
I am banking on
regression that is just what I that is
what I am thinking here I love Jalen
Brown he is on my favorite team he is
one of my favorite players of the past
few years in the NBA but I think Jason
Tatum checking himself out of last game
in the first quarter he is going to jump
in today and say I need to make my mark
early and often and make sure people
know that I'm here today and he's back
at home so the last leg of this which
will also
funny enough be the one leg that uh
either caches or or kills us first will
be Jalen Brown under seven and a half
points in the first quarter
Greg we he didn't lost his mind we
cannot put this in the parlay you're not
about to smoke Us in the first 12
minutes in the first quarter bro I can't
do it I can't do it you're going first
quarter Ryan
at least take his full game under I
don't know bro that is no I think he
could go over it that's the thing I
think he could probably go over his I
think he could go under this and go over
his his full game total oh man this is I
mean no yeah KB 225 said this dude about
to kill the whole bet on that last pick
on the left leg
we went we was trying to be
sure to be you know it's right
trying to pick favorites guys easy
winners coming this is a favorite it's
minus 130. the over is plus yeah you
know we were going for big juice big
juice big juice big juice big juice
big juice I haven't the big juice is the
plus 1100 exact exact series bet that I
gave last week that's probably gonna
cash
dude there's no way we can put this in
the parlay man all right I mean okay do
you wanna if you want me to change it up
I can give you another one but it's also
going to be minus 110.
I have two bets Rocky tonight the other
one's Devin Booker under 32 and a half
points
yeah that's not hidden all right it's
okay it's all right Ryan's driving the
bus I mean now we're in the airplane and
we might not get past the atmosphere
whatever I don't know
I see a stop sign emoji in here I've
never even seen that before so I don't I
don't know where the hell were going but
but you're right
hey Ryan you got it right can you review
your parlay one more time
yeah yeah yeah all right so we've got
malcol brogd did over one and a half
made three Jalen Brown under seven and a
half first quarter points Kevin Durant
six plus rebounds Jamal Murray 20 plus
points and jokic eight plus assists also
also if you'd like the tail and you're
new to FanDuel
he just put five bucks on it and you get
a hundred and fifty dollars
guaranteed the Big G the Big G and it's
a different color lettering guaranteed
there's little guarantees in life
there's getting bonus bets 150 of bonus
bets if he plays five dollars with
FanDuel and
Jalen Brown under seven and a half first
quarter points cashing those are the two
guarantees you have in life
he's guaranteeing stuff he's
guaranteeing stuff
I'm playing
yes it's either that or Devin Booker
under 32 and a half dealer's choice at
least M Taylor says I'm with Ryan today
Devin Booker under
I don't care man it is your show we'll
just leave it just leave it this is nuts
yeah MB and B and B and B let's move on
let's move on let's move on you guys go
ahead we gotta yeah we gotta move on
it's time for Best Bets Ryan jumped the
gun early but that is okay and we know
his best we know one of his actually he
gave us two plays we know his Best Bets
today Jalen Brown under seven and a half
uh first quarter points and then it's
the Devin Booker under what is this
under Ryan 32 and a half 32 and a half
all right uh MB you can give us your
best bet and I'll round It Off
you got it I'm back in the first basket
land I'm going in the late game
I've seen too many easy buckets from the
Suns DeAndre Aiden has won the tip a few
times gone with two plays though KD at
plus 460 and then a long shot I think if
the nuggets are gonna win this game
tonight they're gonna need a big game
for Michael Porter Jr and I think
they're gonna get him involved early
so take them at plus a thousand I Mom I
would even ask if you're feeling frisky
put a little sprinkle on and make a
three to start the game that's better
odds so Kevin Durant Michael Porter Jr
first basket bets for the evening
bowling I'm not here it is I'm not a
first basket guy but I I might dabble
tonight with Michael Porter Jr I love
that play Let's go I love it let's go
hey that's smart bowling that you're
yeah I see what you're doing that's
smart you're doing it on both sides so
you can yeah just in case
stop playing all right um is it my turn
oh yes I think it's my turn so you know
y'all know I'm from the bay and we do
things just a little different and
that's what we're gonna do here we're
gonna introduce something my Best Bets
are going to start coming from the
people from the people themselves so I
was in the DMS you know my DMs were
filled with hate last night after I gave
the Jordan pool play and I don't know
what happened to Jordan pool he's
probably on this plane with us that
Ryan's driving that's why he's not
showing up to his games but uh
all right it's not showing up in the
games but uh
you guys know what I just lost my train
of thought
I legit
just
okay
go ahead I'm gonna pick it back up I'm
gonna pick it back up I'm gonna pick it
back up
because I was getting those DMS that's
where that's that's yeah I was getting
there we go we're back we're back
getting those DMS from all those hateful
DMs
and uh there was this there was this guy
this guy in the DMs
I reveal his name if we win I'll
remember his name next week he told me
he said Malcolm Brogden
he's gonna have a game today
it's gonna go over 15 and a half points
actually I'll tell you when it's mad
Dodger my boy Matt Dodger told me that
Malcolm brother is gonna have a game
today he's gonna go over his 15 and a
half point total so I did my research
I'm like man you know Dodger if I'm a
rock with you let me at least go see
what Malcolm Brock has been doing
against those 76ers and my man's been
average in 19 points against those 76ers
putting up shots he's averaging putting
up uh 14 field goals against you he's
going to put up the shots
I'm rocking with Malcolm Brockton I'm
rocking with Dodger Dodger lead us to
the promised land there it is so we're
going to rock with me
mad Dodger friend of the show dude has
the locks bro I like it and guess what
I just found my squad ride for the night
let's go come on just completely
cleaning the paper the Jalen Brown first
quarter bowling yeah you got you you
lost me on that I cashed for the I
cashed for the community last week
ahead
hey y'all
it's time to get on the butt here yo
it's time to go it's time to get on up
out of here uh my name is Greg Ivy
hopefully y'all tell us Taylor's
Taylor's Taylor's cause today I Feel
Good Vibes my name is Greg Abby for
producer Ryan and Michael Bolin we are
out of here peace
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]